good morning good afternoon uh everyone
my name is jim park
and i'm one of the senior scientists
from military sigma
today i would like to talk about our
microfluidics based
lasik lifestyle imaging platform which
offer precise
on-demand control over various cellular
environment
and says enable what we call dynamic
live cell
imaging
here's the outline of today's
presentation i will briefly cover
two platforms that can enable creation
of more
physiologically relevant in virtual
systems
then i will cover the basics of dynamic
life cell imaging with brief
intro to our celesex platform which
enable dynamic live cell imaging with
any
existing inverted microscopes
main part of the presentation today will
be applications demonstrating the
utility of celiac system
with particular activities given to
membrane-based
platforms
let's start with the background
information of physiologically relevant
in virtual systems
i think we're all aware that the current
tissue culturing method
as shown on the left side of the slide
does not reflect
many individual parameters such as
change in temperature
gas and flow of nutrients which can all
change and fluctuate inside our body
in addition growing cells on flat tissue
culture surfaces does not resemble 3d
spaces
cells are growing in individual
one of the most established way to
create more in
vivoli culture system is to use
microporous membrane platforms
our two examples are shown here
upper images show sertoli cells and
bottom images on the slide show
cable cells in both cases we're
comparing
indicated cells grown on tissue culture
treated plastic surface
compared to the micro forest micro
porous
membrane surfaces notice how cells grown
on membrane surfaces acquire more
in vivo-like morphologies with
well-defined
polarized physiology cells on plastic
surfaces
simply grow as a flat monolayer of cells
in addition to membrane platforms there
is an increasing awareness
that microfluidics can create more
physiologically relevant culturing
system
when coupled with appropriate setups
microfluidics can offer
user-defined on-demand control
of cellular micro environment such as
temperature
gas and media proficient while enabling
continuous life cell imaging we'll cover
much of the microfluidics
in today's talk
let's start with some background
information on dynamic life cell imaging
i think by now it is well established
that live cell imaging offers tremendous
biological insight over more
static imaging due to his steel and
temporal information
example let's take a look at this static
image in the middle of the slide
what you see in the middle of the slide
is bunch of two info sides
we should load it with the costume
indicator fluorescent dye
to simply put not much insight can be
gained
from such a static image perhaps other
than what appears to be
a different level of dioptake as seen by
different fluorescent intensities among
the t cells
however if we are to take a time-lapse
image of these t-cells as showing the
bottom of the slide
we start to gain deeper level of
understanding and awareness
to the spatiotemporal dynamics of the
cells at single cell level
in this particular experiment calcium
indicator
loaded t cells were kept without
disturbance indicated as a resting t
cells and then activated with ionomycin
which causes increasing intracellular
calcium level
very important and key step in
activation of t
while these are snapshots taken from
actual time-lapse image
already couple observations can be made
which were not possible
when we're just looking at the static
image in the middle of the slide
for example we start to notice that the
t cells are actually
oscillating in their calcium level even
during
resting stage and also that there is a
significant level
of heterogeneity among the t cells
in terms of their calcium responses
let's play the movie itself to better
appreciate
what is going on
taken together dynamic live cell imaging
offers
analysis of cellular events at single
cell level
says enabling study population
heterogeneity
study of cellular biology as a function
of microenvironmental perturbation
for example we can study calcium
responses of t cells
before during and after their activation
while we'll control when and how t-cell
agonists
in this case ionomycin is added other
common examples would be dynamic gas
control
where cells grown under non-maxi
condition are subjected to hypoxic
condition
and then brought back to the moxie
condition and time-lapse images are
taken
under these dynamic conditions last but
not least
is a time dimension where we can now
study various cellular responses
such as morphology movement and velocity
intracellular signaling as well as a
cell cell interaction as a function of
time
to obtain spatiotemporal information of
any
given biological system
now let's take a step back and think
about some of the challenges in terms of
building or buying a system
which will enable dynamic lifestyle
imaging dynamic life cell imaging
while it is very powerful tool has these
challenges this is an image from
wikipedia
and nicely demonstrate the complexity of
such a system
they're very large and complex systems
with high price tag requiring
well-trained scientists
to operate also in all cases
additional do it yourself components are
required
control perfusion and fluid capability
in order to create true dynamic imaging
system
these components such as pumps and
precision chambers
with associated controllers will further
create complexity
and increase prices now i do want to
point out that they are
simplified version of such systems that
exist
uh however they're very still expensive
well over seventy thousand dollars
and also simpler systems tend to be
closed systems
with limited capability
switching gears then let's talk about
our celesic platform
what would be key advantages of our
system
to start it is a true turn key
product with the integrated
environmental control system
coupled to microfluidics plate where
cells will be cultured
and imaged the system controller is the
size of a typical 13-inch laptop
in x and y dimension and apr to stack
four of these laptops it'll be in height
as well it is extremely portable
and was built with a mobility in mind
the controller enables software driving
on demand control
of temperature gas and fluidics of the
plates
and so it's making dynamic lifestyle
imaging experiments possible
and it is connected to the plate via
vacuum
manifold software is extremely intuitive
and enables step-by-step protocol
building where each step can be built
with a user-defined time temperature
gas and perfusion parameters such as
flow rate
the plate has standard 96 well footprint
image and center show one of our plate
pre-loaded with a color die
to show individual layout of the
fluidics
as you can see the plate is divided into
six inlet wells on the left side
and two outlet wells on right side
connected to the central tissue culture
chamber area
each of these inlet wells connected via
microfluidic channel
to the central tissue culture chamber
where cells are grown
and imaged and then there is an exit
channel
where waste and used media from the cell
chamber will be delivered to the outlet
wells
as you can see in this cartoon for each
row indicated as a group one
two three and four all the individual
well
within the group are connected to tissue
chamber area via
individual microfluidic channels which
are colored lines
this enables up to four independent
experiments
to be conducted per plate when the plate
is connected to the controller
via manifold media or reagent
in each of the inlet wells can be
pressed down
via positive pressure this will then
move the media
or reagent from that well into the
tissue culture chamber area
and then we'll exit to the outer wells
essentially this creates a system where
any desired media
reagent can be precisely delivered to
cells in the chamber area
at desired time for specific duration
and with specific flow rate since the
plate can be temperature and
gas control we now have a system
that can be uh they can offer ability to
control cellular micro environment
in dynamic on demand fashion
in addition the plate material is also
made of gas permeable polymer to allow
dynamic gas control
and the bottom of the plate is made of
n1.5 glass
for clear imaging including confocal
applications
uh last thing i would like to mention uh
is that the uh since the
these are microfluidic plates we also
introduce
specific micro dimensional features that
can be used for
certain applications such as the imaging
of suspension cells
or maintenance of chemotactic gradient
now let's move on to the main part of
the talk
our system can be connected to two
independent gas outlets
so in this example we can create nomoxic
and hypoxic conditions
using gas switching ability the middle
image shows
fluorescent intensity of reverse oxygen
sensor
rtbp which will decrease fluorescence
with the increasing oxygen concentration
and vice versa
fluorescent was measured from the tissue
culture chamber of our plate
while we changed gas compositions
dynamically
time is indicated on the x-axis rtdp for
essence
is indicated on y-axis arrows indicates
the time point at which gas switching
was initiated as you can see
rtdt fluorescence increases as we put
tissue chamber under hypoxic condition
starting at t equals 2 hours
you will also notice when we put the
tissue chamber under normoxi condition
around t equals 6 hours fluorescence
starts to decrease
which we then switch back to normalcy
condition at around t equals
10 hours with the ensuing increase in
rtdc fluorescence
the image on the right shows special
responses under hypoxic
and demoxy condition by measuring
expression level of hyphen alpha
which is a key transcription factor
under cellular hypoxia
itdp fluorescence is indicating a blue
line
as expected as the cells are subjected
to hypoxic and
as seen by the black line and then later
on
as the cells are subjected to no moxie
condition
we see fluorescence of rtd feed
decreasing
which in turn is followed rapidly by
decreased
expression of heaphone alpha
we're also looking at gap intensity as a
control
in purple line and it shows no
meaningful change under
changing oxygen levels
next we would like to show you the
lesson will be generated using biocheck
or hypoxia lifestyle dye
this is a cell permeable lifestyle dye
which becomes fluorescent under hypoxic
condition
inside of cells here we're looking at
a4c1 cells
loaded with and without dye after 16
hours incubation
under hypoxic condition to show its
specificity
now let's take a look at the livestock
movie
next we will look at the autophagon
formation under hypoxia using
fluorescent lysosomal marker
lc3 under hypoxic addition cellular
stress will induce formation
of punctate autophasms and this can be
visualized and measured
based on lifestyle imaging let's take a
look at the movie
next applications uh we're looking at
intracellular trafficking of proteins
in this case we are examining
internalization of fluorescent egf
receptor
upon egf activation you'll notice upon
the addition of egf
the receptors uh start to collapse
together
which then gets internalized to
endoscope compartment
with characteristic punctate patterns
again let's take a closer look
with the lifestyle movie
now i want to cover perhaps one of the
most widely investigated cellular
behavior
which are migration and invasion
for this type of studies membrane
platforms are very widely used
in addition membrane platforms are well
characterized and established
for barrier models as well but these
will be covered
in later slides for now let's start with
migration
and asian applications using membrane
inserts
for these a pore size of the membrane is
critical
and in most cases 8 micron pore size is
the most
commonly used ones
the difference between migration
animation is really about the presence
of ecm gel matrix
if the acid is performed without ecm gel
in presence of chemotactic gradient then
it is a migration assay
if the acid is performed in presence of
ecm gel
then it is an invasion assay as cells
need to move through the ecm matrix
towards the chemoattractant in both
cases
directional movement of cells towards
the chemoattractant
can be measured simply by removing cells
or cells and ecm gels in case of the
invasion assay
from the top side of the membrane and
increasing cells on the bottom
side of the membrane
here are some example data generated
using 96 well middle cell plate
with 8.0 micron pore size plots on the
right side of the spy
show fluorescent intensity on the cells
from the bottom side of the membrane
after
migration assay for both plots cellular
fluorescence is plotted
on y-axis plot on the upper
right shows the effect of serum
concentration
on cellular migration the concentration
of serum used
are indicated on x-axis
the plot on the lower right shows
inhibitory effect of
rhd peptide on cellular migration
induced by
0.5 percent serum inhibitor
concentrations are indicated
on x-axis
now for invasion assay which is
essentially 3d form of a migration assay
using ecm gel matrix there are some
couple key takeaways
when setting up the assays the bar graph
on the right
shows level of cellular invasion
reflecting the level of cells that
moved through the ecm matrix and were
present on the bottom side of the
membrane
you'll notice that concentration of ecm
gel
plays very critical role
it is very important to dilute the ecm
gel
to identify optimal assay concentration
if concentration of ecm gel is too high
then cells cannot invade through the gel
as the matrix is too hard and you will
get
pretty much zero signal from the cells
if the concentration of ecm gel is too
low
then there will not be enough matrix to
cause invasion
which in that case the assay will simply
become a migration assay
also consider that ecmgel itself also
contains chemoattractant
which can reduce signal to noise ratio
in this example batch concentration
would be between 6
to 12 percent gels
while migration innovation is widely
performed on membrane platforms
they do not allow live cell imaging for
for obvious reasons
uh so here we now show how microfluidics
can enable life cell imaging of cellular
migration
while maintaining chemo gradient
we have a microfluidic culture chamber
that is connected to
two parallel flow channels
cells are a culture in the middle
chamber and chemotactin is profused
onto an adjacent channel as you can see
in the images at the bottom
cell will migrate towards the presence
of chemoattractant
let's take a closer look with the
livestream movie
next i would like to cover life cell
imaging of suspension spells which pose
unique challenges
due to their non-audio nature as you can
see on the
image at the at the bottom left during
laxal imaging
suspension cells will move up and down
making it
impossible to imagine cells at single
cell level
however if we introduce microfluidics
ceiling
feature as shown by the cartoon on the
upper panel of the slide
then we can confine the cells under
single focal plane
and enable clear visualization of cells
doing
by cell imaging
for example we'll be able to maintain in
great detail
cell cell interaction of t cells with
that of antigen presenting b
cells these are snapshots taken from a
livestock movie
now let's take a closer look with live
movie itself
here's another example where we are
examining t cell autopsies at single
cell level
uh we're using cd95 activation to induce
program cell deaths
and then visualizing the cellular events
using caspase-3 specific apotopsies pro
as well as annexin 5. let's take a look
at the lifestyle movie
i just want to cover a few more things
uh one is a long-term culturing aspect
using microfluidics
since we are using very small volume of
media with continuous perfusion
we can culture cells for a very long
time turn our examples
for 21-day neuronal culture on the left
and four-day culture
on the right
of course the most established way to do
long-term culture is to use membrane
platform
let's take a look at 21-day caico
culture performed using plastic tissue
culture surface
versus 0.4 micron polycarbonate
you'll notice dramatic differences
between plastic surface and membrane
surfaces
with later producing cells resembling
in vivo polarized morphology
let's take closer look at using confocal
imaging
lastly i want to close off by going over
some 3d applications
using ecm gel cells can be loaded onto
our microfluidics plate with ecm gels
and allotted from 3d structures as shown
on this slide
we have a movies playing on the next
slide
now the summary and closing remarks
uh so in summary we have actually wide
range of plates
uh that specifically caters towards a
specific customer
applications our plates can be broadly
divided into mammalian plates
this can be identified the letter m in
the front
as well as we have a suit of plates that
are useful
for microbiology life cell imaging
applications as well
and these are shown on the lower right
part of the slide
we are also enjoying growing list of
publications
our papers are very well cited in
high-ranked
prestigious journals currently we have
well over 700 publications
citing our platform based on the google
scholar
key search
so in summary cellular biology is
complex
uh and it's dynamically changing
in terms of the microenvironment as well
as
its responses dynamic lifestyle imaging
is an indispensable tool therefore
to better understand these events
also last but not least user micropores
membranes
enable creation of more physiologically
relevant
in vitro culture systems
with that i would like to thank everyone
for today's webinar
uh if you have any questions please do
not hesitate to contact me
and our website simply just type in cell
lasik.com
and there you will be able to find a
much more information
once again thanks for your time